you can't trust nobody these days smh oh
man you're supposed to be my friend
okay you know what you look like with
that beard a Little League coach I know
you're not talking about my beard yeah
I'm talking about you gee I'll try to be
smart with those glasses and blues a
terrible color on you drink and [ __ ]
like an idiot I don't even know what I
did to you you know exactly what you did
is this about the time I roasted him in
front of Pamela I just roasted you in
front of Pamela oh no this is not about
the time you Rosa you can what is this
about
don't play dumb I'm not I'm just
honestly I just don't know what you're
talking about to come over to me and
confront me like
look man I'm sorry
oh just one sec Zach finishing up
something here okay I see what you're
doing but I'm here face to face talking
to you I'm sorry I don't know what
you're talking about Zach okay but just
one sec okay that's it
I'm gonna just go take me and my little
league beard here and just go home
because you're being ridiculous
stop easy all right
I'm sorry you can stop subtweeting at me
now Thank You Brent all I wanted was an
apology actually do coached in a wig
called friends mommy bombers we planned
Sunday if you want to stop by